Brady kachuck the captain of the Senators he
enjoyed a career year last year in virtually
every category he's looking forward to Leading
his Club to the playoffs for the first time in
six years underway here from Canada Life Center
of course these two teams will play twice in the
regular season not until after Christmas as it's
cleared to Center reached for there by CL zeru
carried in by slitz who really broke out last year
with a 90 point season there's a sharp ankle shot
kicked Away by heluk Unis cor pasalo signed the
5-year deal after he was traded from Columbus to
La this past season and he'll certainly be under
the microscope in Ottawa kach Chuck's pass makes
it Wing in behind the goal horsey to Dello turning
is Appleton he looked to redirected he can't get
it over the line and a breakaway pass clu alone to
the back hands scores what a move by giru and the
Senators strike first it's one- nothing leads to
speed so a headman pass from Dello but he catches
Appleton a little bit flat footed He bobbles the
puck look how quickly kachu comes in to recover
that loose Puck and JW read the play the entire
time he stays low and slow on the wide side and
it receives the puck look at that backand forehand
he opens the net right up for the game's first
goal the 35-year-old scored 35 times for a career
high last season we start the second period with
a clean sheet of ice minute 52 seconds left on
the Ridley Greg penalty as he cools his heels in
the Box we did get official word that V hola is
finished for the night after inuring worked his
way in that pass was cut off he fights to get
it back held at the line by P some room for f
he sling to miss the C good save by forsberg it
may have rang off the iron what an opportunity
for Cole per fetty as he makes a little dish pass
over to Nestico who cuts to the forehand and gets
the shot off he wants and the Jets Conor trying
to keep it away from giru Josh Morris he steps
up shoots it kick save Rebound in front and valard
floats it to the gloves for for can't squeeze and
yet able to win this one so it's a DDD pass and
an absolute BB from morsey there's the big body
valard he gets the shot off forsberg her back to a
five on four situation for the Jets again one shot
on that five on three in they come shot Le drags
it hamers it stopped and held by forsberg see it
there as Neer Rider almost in trouble with that
pucky and nowhere to go for fenny swallowed up
by Sanderson the pass for kachuck Freddy kachuck
gets right in the stick ripped out of his hand as
huk went down and it's grabbed there by Peretti
yes they are hungry for loose pucks tonight those
senators and it's not just the speed to force the
turnovers but it's the transition to do something
with it where they're good to defensively and
then they're dangerous offensively all in the
same shift I have follow block by pushed into the
corner and a light bump there as it momentum took
him right into helar the pass onto the Stick of
Appleton Mason Appleton on a breakaway right in
stopped by forberg in the blue paint and earlier
def or offense from good defense that's that a
sense of anticipation from Mason Appleton who had
opportunities earlier to shoot the puck chose not
to well he does here with the breakway well
earned well you knew appon had the wheels to
get himself a clear cut break away but just could
not finish five goals in 41 games for appon last
year excellent opportunity that time and almost
another paral break at least for Lowry but he
couldn't knock the pass down Shi into the Zone
there by STL be to Center Appleton again Baron
Zu reaching trying to W him off thrown to the net
off Lowry forsberg is down Sanders is sitting at
the goal line a big pile up in the blue ice Bailey
with some room centering pass tipped wide by CH
didn't get much on it spel got it back Josh Bailey
again snapshot Sanderson that block shot gets to
the boards with under three to go here in the
second period kept inly by teraso Chon Sanderson
finds CH one more time the shot crew fought off
by haluk whacked at by peon under 10 left and
the Neer Rider minor another penalty coming
up the win a pick that's a shot by Sanderson
good stuff by huk and a drive and they score
Bailey turns and fires and makes it two nothing
Ottawa the veteran of over a thousand games 15
years with the New York Islanders a player Tri
out he does a good job he is the one that jars
the pot loose gets out of the open Ice spins and
fires and as the power play expires the senator
score their second goal Bailey's first of the
preseason he had eight goals last year in 64
games this comes with 234 to go in the second
this is this game's a lot quicker than it has
been in these first few preseason games so it
gets you a chance to prepare for when it becomes
real here in about another week good shot took it
behind the net brace for the bub L shot zo right
on big rebound jaru smart pass to good shot his
shot off the post after it grazed hu how about
that tea up there by jaru and almost three nothing
but can they use another veteran that's been
there done that they've got CL Drew Josh Bailey
maybe wouldn't hurt his well JS could use a goal
to State the obvious but a sheru hopping on it
backhander stop and he gets the rebound Sanderson
11 goals last season lugs it into the Zone met by
Samberg got a fact that chck CH pass off the Stick
of Baron but it's Smo with a shot he whipped that
one wide shabat CH now tereno up top for Jacob CH
tereno is a lethal wrist shot he hit a teammate
smle with it bounces right back to teraso 45 left
in the penalty Sanderson loading up again teraso
go Line pass and the shot off the Quick Pass and
that's when you start taking penalties you're
reaching you maybe don't have the body position
you normally would have if you're playing fast
Shabbat blistered that one off the goal post
you can hear that one all the way in Brandon th
Shabbat good Chuck slot pass JW gave it back good
feed KU nice stop there by halot his best of the
game by far he got to the spot in time made a
terrific save there's a drive and another stop
a stick save that time and shut down the ice by
Dy D in the shift on the power play a seam pass
hard and flat one timer hell but nope gets the
first one gets the second one and because of
number 37 this game is he's cautious with it lost
the handle shely turns doesn't get enough on it
Jake Sanderson walks it off stopped by Conor
hellu another terrific [Applause] save and
the puck pops loose and it's Bailey away with it
Bailey finding terce anle he wobbles that into the
corner centering pass and chran scores Jacob
Chan off a nice speed teed it up with the slot
power play goal makes it 3 nothing Ottawa how
fast this Puck comes off of CH stick it's a
nice little simple entry right so you got
teraso that plows the way through and Josh
Bailey is going to pick up his second point of
this game perfect pass and an even better shot
bar down from chicken 5 seconds left of the
morrisy minor shabat stla stla between a pair
of just look at the ble not stopped by hellu
so six skaters out for Winnipeg as they try to
get that elusive goal against forsburg been a
lot of travel the last few days for the Ottawa
Senators but didn't show any fatigue tonight
they beat the Jets by a score of three nothing